yep okay good evening councillors ladies
and gentlemen and welcome to this
virtual meeting of council
first item is apologies i am aware that
councillor harding is on
other council business and hopes to join
the meeting at approximately 7 30
can i ask if anyone is aware of any
other apologies
counselor canola mr man thank you
council tarakinola can we make a note of
that
any other apologies
okay that's good um can i remind
everybody when participating in today's
virtual meeting
please remember to mute your microphone
when not speaking
to use the chat facility to indicate to
the chair that you wish to speak
and please only use the chat facility
for this purpose
and to unmute your microphone when
invited to speak
by the chair and tonight on those items
where a vote is called for
we are intend to vote on matters using
the polling option
at the appropriate time i will announce
that i am putting the matter
to the vote a window will appear on your
screen and you will be asked to click
one of the three options available for
against
or abstain once you have selected your
preference
please click submit at the bottom of the
window
and the outcome of the vote will appear
on the screen once all votes
are in uh should we have any technical
problems this evening
uh since we are hosting the meeting
virtually should we encounter any
difficulties it may be necessary to
adjourn in the first
instance for 15 minutes and updates and
any rejoining instructions
will be emailed to members if we are
unable to broadcast a meeting live on
youtube
we would hope to upload a recording at a
later date
announcements may i take this
opportunity to recognize those citizens
and persons connected with trafford who
were named
in her majesty's the queen's birthday
honors list
mrs amanda jane meltzen of hail was
awarded the cbe for services for
education
michelle helen ramsden of ermston was
awarded the obe for services to children
in greater manchester and mr marcus
rashford of bolden
was awarded the mbe for services to
vulnerable children in the uk
during kobit 19. i'm sure you will join
with me
in conveying the council's recognition
for their achievements
and richly deserved recognition does the
leader of the council wish to make any
announcements this evening
yes please mr mayor before i do so could
i have councillor dylan's apologies i
should have done that
um earlier mr mayor um just with your
indulgence mr mayor i'd like to update
all members
on the um position that i am taking as
leader in discussions at
um greater manchester level in terms of
the recommendations that we would put
forward
or should i say submission that we would
put forward it has not necessarily been
asked for in terms of
our tier status um at the review point
on the 16th of december so colleagues
will be aware
and that we were placed into tier three
restrictions in spite of being
um below the national average at that
juncture
um as i say we weren't consulted on that
and moving forward the intention from
greater manchester is to
um right to government this week to make
clear
um the the view of leaders in the city
region
so just just for um members
understanding really i will be
based on our um coronavirus rates in
terms of prevalence of 87.6 cases per
100 000 which is now very significantly
below
the england average be asking that
we are placed into tier 2
at that review point on the basis that
all of our indicators are looking
extremely healthy
and that we are now significantly lower
than
um many other areas in terms of cases
per 100
000 so it's just so that all members are
aware of that
and that i can proceed in a transparent
way in making those representations mr
mayor it's a
matter of considerable interest for
residents so i just wanted to update all
members on that
thank you thank you councillor weston
um i'd like to introduce my chaplain to
say a few words this evening i should
have done that earlier
it was remiss of me um i invite i invite
councillor father
gerald murphy to say a few words from
saint anne's
church in stratford now the jed
good evening um we gathered together
in the name of the father and the son
and the holy spirit
amen god our father we come together in
your name to ask
your help during these difficult days
you are god who speaks us with clarity
and truth
and we pray that you will light our way
today
even when the future is cloudy and
uncertain
you're always there to guide embrace and
involve each of us and each member of
the traffic community
may our concern for each other and for
the world in which we live
be the force which leads to solutions
which are good for all the community
and for the world of which we are
stewards
help us see past our differences because
we know
that it is you who we serve in and
through
our community and we ask this in jesus
name
amen amen thank you father jed
counselor acton have you any anything to
announce on behalf of the pandemic
scrutiny committee
yes thank you mr mayor um the the only
thing that i want to say really
is that um
i i we we had our last
pandemic scrutiny meeting last week and
i would like to
uh put on record the thanks to all the
members
of the committee for all the work and
commitment
during the last eight months i'd also
like to thank the scrutiny officers who
worked
uh really hard in in that time clearly
it's been a very
difficult uh period for for all of us
but as we move to the next um
new year that um you know we will be
bringing back the
other committees and i think that is the
right thing to do
and i i would like to thank all the
executive members
and all the uh officers directors
and uh the other organizations that have
contributed when we've been asking very
difficult questions
to to those members and
officers and they've done a fantastic
job in
researching all the issues that we've
raised and actually
answering the questions in the way that
they have i think it's been a very
meaningful
period in terms of scrutiny uh and it's
one that
uh i think was necessary to hold to
account
uh officers and members through that
very very difficult period obviously
there's still a long way to go in terms
of the pandemic but
we can see the light at the end of the
tunnel
but thank you very much mr man thank you
councillor acton
item number two is questions i can
report that eleven questions were
submitted for tonight's meeting
two from councillors amnesty carey and
morgan
and one a piece from councillors mrs
blackburn it's blackburn
boys but chilton and evans
however councillor kerry has since
withdrawn his question
about democratic process as a result of
council meetings
reverting to their usual times in the
new year
councillor chilton's question was
previous provisionally withdrawn
but will now be put so that he may
receive a brief
verbal update therefore we will proceed
and without discussion to each of the
each of the questions shall we dealt
with
in the order they were received question
number one
councillor anster your first question
please
well thank you mr mayor um my question
is this council faces challenging budget
constraints and difficult decisions for
the administration and indeed all
members
are likely to be required in future part
of the response to this challenge should
be an increased focus in increasing the
council tax base
through building new homes please could
the executive member outline what steps
he is taking to ensure the planning and
development service
adopts a greater focus and a pro-growth
approach to securing development
especially in existing urban areas
thank you mr man thank you councillor
honestly councillor wright
executive member for housing and
regeneration would you like to respond
please
thank you mr mayor thank you
the question has been published and has
been sent through to
uh members i'm happy to through the
answer again now
[Music]
um i think we've got a technical issue
there counselor right we
didn't hear your reply to counselor
auntie's question could you just
try and repeat that please apologies mr
mayor sorry about that
um no all i was saying was the uh the
answer has been published on our website
and councillorancy i believe has seen a
copy of that answer uh if you wish you
should run through that now if you
haven't seen it i'm happy to do so
otherwise if you wish me to move on to
me onto a supplementary that would also
be fine
thank you mr mayor i think i think we've
gone to the supplementary question
counselor and steve do you have a
supplementary question
uh i do mr mayor but having not seen the
answer so i will try and now
i'll try it now let me is it what might
my support
sorry counselor honestly well if you
haven't seen the answer the last council
the right to uh
to respond to you verbally council
running
yeah thank you mr mayor happy to do that
uh this council is committed to securing
housing in the borough
particularly considering the high cost
of homes both for sale and rent and the
overall lack of social rented in
affordable housing
for example the council established a
trafford affordable housing fund
using section 106 monies to provide
grant support to register providers
to develop new social rented housing to
date the council
has provided 1.5 million pounds of grant
to trafford housing trust
for 30 new one and two-bedroom socially
rented apartments in templeley
that's anticipated to be completed in
april 21.
as additional section 106 monies are
received by the council
then the further call for schemes that
can be supported by the fund
will be issued to the registered
providers we are currently working
closely with the greater manchester
combined
authority to maximise the use of the 80
million brownfield land fund in trafford
we have successfully secured transform
allocations of 4.06 million
support housing delivery on brownfield
land at the carrington village
botanical gardens paragon house and
royal canal works sites
unlocking a total of 594 homes
we are currently preparing submissions
to gmca as part of tranche 2 of that
fund
we continue to work closely with homes
england to draw down the housing
infrastructure
fund allocations of 8.4 million at
future carrington
and 4.08 million at trafford waters
unlocking unlocking a total of 1075 new
homes
with regards to the number of new
housing developments the total number of
units with current planning permission
equates to 8009.
for 2021 440 units have been completed
to date with an additional 55 forecast
to be completed by the end of the
financial year
495 in total it is worth noting that
housing development has been
adversely affected by the kobe crisis
for future years 1
920 units of forecast to completing 2122
and 1313 in 2223
the council's joint joint venture
agreement arrangement with bruntwood has
now secured planning consent of the
lumina village scheme
that will deliver up to 750 new homes
the former kellogg's office site
alongside a new primary school and
commercial floor space in the civic
quarter area
the council is continuing to progress
development of the civic quarter area
action plan that will provide a robust
planning framework for the delivery
of further new homes across the civic
quarter area
the council has appointed the
contractors sedan to deliver deliver our
18 million pound
residential scheme for 86 new homes
including affordable homes
on the site of the former salman straits
core building
the flagship scheme will contribute to
the wider regeneration of cell town
centre
and support our policy of building more
housing on brownfield sites
in july 19 the council's expression of
interest
for stretford town centre was
shortlisted for the future high street
fund
a full business case was submitted to
mhclg
on the 5th of june 20 seeking capital
investments of 17.6 million
to deliver the enabling infrastructure
required to unlock wider redevelopments
of the town centre the emerging proposal
set out in the full business case
will deliver 615 new homes alongside new
retail and commercial developments
the council is continuing preparation of
the stratford area action plan
with further public public consultation
held in october this year
the area action plan will provide a
robust planning framework for the
delivery of new homes
in stratford town centre and the
widening wider area
the trafford local plan will then set
policies for how these new homes will
meet local need in terms of
affordability mixed type etcetera
the council's planning service already
operates with a focus on growth
and making the best and most efficient
use of land
in the past three years 87 percent of
major residential planning applications
have been approved this pro-growth
agenda is subject to appropriate checks
and balances
to ensure the development coming forward
is of an appropriate quality
commensurate with the positive
attributes of the borough
which make it such an attractive place
to live work and invest
and that development contributes
appropriately and proportionately
to the infrastructure requirements it
generates
securing appropriate contributions to
future infrastructure means that future
growth will not stall
when existing infra infrastructure is at
capacity
the planning service has granted
permission for 1898 residential units
since march 2020 for example the 750
units the former kellogg site already
mentioned
367 units at elsinore road old trafford
and 263 units at sail west
these are all sites within the existing
urban area
there are a further 1558 units in the
pipeline
pending the formal decision of the
planning committee and with the likely
officer
recommendation of approval again all in
the existing
urban area or on allocated sides the
bespoke pre-application advice service
provided
offered by the planning service has had
significant take up this financial year
as developers seek greater certainty in
the market
several schemes have been worked up from
first principles in partnership with
developers and architects
and that and that input welcomed and are
now coming forward
as planning applications the civic
quarter area action plan which will
shortly go out for public
consultation on its publication draft
before being submitted to planning
inspectors
has taken advantage of the obvious
developer interest and capacity of sites
in the civic area
quarter area to drive for the delivery
of up to 4 000 new homes
this is a capacity led plan to deliver
medium to high density development in
area of
disparate disparate land ownerships
the council is also committed to
ensuring that sites in the urban area
and the strategic locations are
delivered and has published an updated
housing delivery test action plan
to ensure that the numerous planning
permissions it does grant
are translated into delivery on the
ground
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
wright
counselor anste do you have a
supplementary question uh just just
briefly mr matt and can i thank
councillor wright for that
um comprehensive answer it's really
appreciated the question is that
uh notwithstanding the comments that
he's made around the number of planning
permissions that have been granted
and there are brownfield applications
that are struggling through the
subjective elements of the planning
process
viability density and design and given
the comments around covered and the need
to continue to attract investment in the
borough
and we've been trying to do this
actually but will he commit to sort of
meet with me so that we
can run through those applications with
him and make sure that our future
policies
are continuing to align to the
pro-growth aspirations that he's
outlined
yeah uh thank you council once again
thank you mr mayor more than happy to
arrange a meeting with
councillor anthony a suitable time going
forward thank you
okay thank you very much um question
two was from councillor carey um but
that's been withdrawn
councillor question three councillor
anste please can you put your second
question
thank you mr matt and i have seen the
response to this um to this question but
the question was can the executive
member confirm what funding was
allocated to the council in transit one
of the eatf fund and any other funding
the council has received for the rollout
of schemes
we also provide a breakdown of all
expenditure incurred today on skids
thank you council right said do you need
to comment you have published
an answer thank you thank you mr mayor
if council and i've seen that it's been
published on the website so i'm happy to
move
uh straight to the supplementary in that
case
a yeah question thank you mr mayor
supplementary is um
councillor's head will be aware of the
strength of feeling on oxford road in my
ward and on a lack of progress on
implementing a scheme here where unlike
schemes
there is almost unanimous support for it
uh will he therefore commit this evening
given that the trench two funding has
now been confirmed
uh that by the end of this week or
certainly early next week
that there'll be a clear plan from the
council about what it intends to do
to implement a scheme on oxford road
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor anthony councillor
ted
thank you mr van impe thank you
councillor i'm speaker you're
supplementary
are you alluded to yet we haven't yet as
yet finalized the full story of anton's
two
it has been delayed significantly uh
last couple of months
and it's really put us behind uh part of
the problem with toronto
is that of course obviously whilst been
waiting all this time
for the implementation of date of march
hasn't changed in that sense of it
so it's putting everybody on under a lot
of a personal moment but there's
not so much just the monies which we
obviously need to get full clarification
it's actually how we can actually spend
that and the restrictions that the
government is putting around it uh
i'm hoping to be in a clear position
within the next few days as councillor
anderson alludes
to tell the public and i went sure as
soon as i had that information full of
hand
and it has gone for the necessary checks
i'm sure that council honestly and
indeed all members of council actually
have that updated information mr mayor
thank you
thank you councillor i'd said um
question four
councillor miss blackburn can you ask
your question
yes uh thank you uh thank you mr mayor
would the executive member comment on
the usage
of pavement frontage seating areas by
bars
converted from retail establishments
with regard to health and well-being
due to the narrow pavements are the
licensees
creating an effective barrier between
smokers
and passing pedestrians
thank you council blackburn um can i
invite councillor outside
executive member for environmental and
regulatory services
to respond please thank you
mr mayor this is a relatively short one
so i will just uh run through it quickly
where tables and chairs are placed on
the public highway
a bar or cafe should always obtain the
proper pavement license from the council
full details of this can be found on the
website
this includes guidelines which are
designed to ensure
there is always sufficient width of
pavement for passing pedestrians
alongside guidelines on the use of
street furniture
barriers and signs in particular
the policy has been updated to include
provisions
for pavement areas to be non-smoking
establishments will need to provide
separate external areas
separate external smoking areas if they
wish to be in line with the law
unfortunately not every establishment
has applied for such a license
so if in doubt please do check with
highways transport
and environment team by emailing street
cafe
suite cafe license at trafford.gov uk
or indeed uh contact myself or indeed
overseas
and we'll actually happily look into
problems in that respect thank you mr
mayor
thank you councillor miss backburn do
you have a supplementary question
yes mr mayor thank you um thank you
thank you for answering the question
um counter-arts head um in the um
1980 highway act part 7a and the
business and planning act
2020 section 4.2 there's no mention
of any barriers between licensed
premises
and pedestrians it does state
that it has to be a two meter um
distance between
smokers but it doesn't actually it says
between smokers and non-smokers
but it doesn't actually specify um sort
of pedestrians passing
could you comment on that and could you
say if you have
any uh local um uh
any sort of local um sorry uh
local conditions that exist whereby you
could insist on
proper barriers being created
thank you mr mayor and uh councilman for
your supplementary because i highlighted
the moment again uh these particular
areas
that we're putting in these temporary
measurements as part of the uh
recovery measures uh where they're
actually put onto public space
uh land beyond uh there actually are
they are no smoking as indicated a
moment ago
so do not permit smoking in those places
that if the businesses wish to have a
smoking area you need to be
on their land which is clearly separate
we do not allow smoking
within these if you obviously see that
smoking is taking place they're not
adhering to the terms of their licence
uh and if you suspect they do not have
one then you can please do contact us
but i'll assure you
in that sense that if they are doing it
on public land
and these are these temporary schemes
they are not committed
to allow smoking in that sense thank you
mr mayor
thank you councillor ted question five
councillor chilton would you like to ask
your question
please thank you mr um
would the lead member for education
advise when her department plans to
consult with the public and ward members
about the increase to three-four entry
at first primary school
in national mersey this will have a
significant impact on the footprint and
local infrastructure which is already
congested thank you mr mayor
would councillor carter the lead member
for education
like to respond please um thank you
councillor chilton for your question
um i think members are aware there is
significant pressure on primary school
places in the cell west area
and following this summer we can now
report that every
school is full in reception and year two
and year four
and i know i helped quite a few members
in this meeting try and find places for
children this summer in the sale area
so we're very aware that we've got a
problem there and the education in early
years basic need
capital report is scheduled to come to
executive
in january and it does include the
proposal to increase the first primary
school from two form entry to three form
entry
to meet the needs of local children
within the catchment area
including additional demand which will
be created from new housing developments
in sale west
the proposal bills on the emergency
measure where we've
had to set up a an additional classroom
really for 10 children
who we didn't get placed over the summer
um
and if the decision is made exec to
proceed
then we will have a statutory
consultation for
the process to expand the school a full
options
appraisal takes place prior to
developing a proposal
to increase capacity in a particular
school and this is driven by demand and
intelligence about school
sites not through an expression of
interest
with regards to the impact on footprint
and local infrastructure this proposal
is to accommodate local children
if they don't get a place at the first
then they will have to travel further
afield
thank you councillor carter councillor
children do you have a supplementary
question
um given this
extra places that will be required to be
known about for some time
um will the lead member agree to meet
with
or at least the corporate director agree
to meet with ward members
and the board of governors at that
school which has not happened
um before that goes to the executive
please thank you
um absolutely we'll we'll we're more
than happy to meet with you councillor
chilton
okay thank you question six councillor
carey
please would you like to put your
question this evening
uh thank you mr mayor uh a recent press
release reported their plans for 48 town
houses
and 38 apartments to be built at the
former cell magistrates court
and also the significant new homes at
the sale west estate nearby
can the lead member for education tell
me which schools
in the area have capacity to receive the
additional pupils that these
developments will bring
that's my carter okay thanks uh
councillor carey um as you know we
calculate how many school places we need
based on the well-established formula of
three
pupils per year per hundred homes
excluding um studio flats and one
bedroom properties
so you're talking here of 86 homes
we imagine that will generate two pupils
per year group for the
primary phase so we're looking at 12 to
14 children here
as with all developments we request a
monetary contribution from the developer
linked to the pupil numbers which is
used towards the cost of future school
expansion projects
this development is in the cell west
school place planning area
and proposals are being developed to
increase the capacity
in the primary sector to meet demand as
per
my previous answer to councillor chilton
thank you councillor carter councillor
kerry do you have a supplementary
question
yes please mr mayor and thank you
councillor carter for your answer
and trafford's housing target up to 2037
as reported earlier
is 18 546 homes
and has actually identified land for
twenty one thousand two hundred and
eighty nine to meet it and i'd like to
ask councillor
uh carter today please which land uh and
where lan has been identified
to build uh these new schools uh across
the whole borough for the provision
that's going to be required for these
new children
um thank you very much councillor kerry
i think if you've been in the exact
meeting where we looked at the greater
manchester spatial framework i talked
about how
that would enable us to plan schools
more effectively
um evidently that hasn't got the support
that we wanted
so we do have a school sufficiency
committee and we will be looking at
where we'll be best suited to place la
uh schools in the future we've obviously
already got the one alluded to
by um councillor wright and we will be
looking at
where we need to situate schools
thank you count uh question seven
councillor bars can i ask you to put
your question now please
thank you mr mayor uh communication with
residents must be a paramount objective
of any administration never more so than
in the midst of a global pandemic
there was crisis for the uk since world
war ii
given this scenario could the leader
explain why there was so much
procrastination
before the decision was finally taken to
deliver an advisory leaflet
to every house in the borough with that
leaflet itself being made delivery
itself being made by volunteers at times
using efficient walking routes provided
by opposition councillors
and furthermore on what basis was the
decision taken
more recently to deliver a second
leaflet via the royal mail
as opposed to those same volunteers that
was
what must have been a significant cost
to residents
thank you mr mayor thank you please
could the leader of the council
respond please certainly mr mayor thank
you
uh so in terms of the first legal there
was no procrastination
um there was careful consideration of
whether it would be appropriate and safe
to deliver a lethal in the first few
months of the pandemic
when the country was in full lockdown so
given that mutual aid groups had already
been established
through neighbourhood schemes and indeed
that they had already undertaken some
liquidity activity there was also
significant potential for duplication
within that
there was also of course a need and
clearly councillor boys considers this
procrastination
to stand up community hubs at extremely
short notice along with a number of
other services
that have to be stood up in response to
the pandemic that we would wish to
include
on any information submitted to
residents so this was never going to be
an immediate activity by the time that
we
felt confident that it was safe to ask
volunteers to support
um delivery uh the leaflet went out but
it's important to also recognize the
distinction made in terms of why this
was delivered by volunteers rather than
the postal service because as you will
know mr mayor without any disrespect to
postal workers
um in trafford there were a significant
number of um workers off sick or
self-isolating during that period
meaning that delivery services through
the royal mail were exceptionally patchy
with residents reporting to me
routinely complaining that they had not
received post
for several weeks so i'm very grateful
to all of those volunteers
mr man who supported delivery and indeed
counsel the boys to political parties
locally
not only opposition parties who both
helped with that delivery and who
provided leafleting rounds certainly i
provided them for the
14 awards with labour representation out
of 21 in this borough and i'm grateful
to others who did so
um in terms of the second leaflet
delivery council of boys you may be
aware that it was your government
procrastinating in the midst of a second
significant wave of coronavirus and that
gave us more time to prepare
as for those of us with common sense it
was inevitable
that we would have to take some form of
further lockdown
having those services that i referred to
earlier already stood up and in place
the community hubs
and all of those other services meant
that we were
able to produce that leaflet quickly and
efficiently
and given that we knew that that
lockdown could come at any time
and because we have that time to prepare
it was felt the best thing to do was to
arrange timely delivery but i have to
say
that the irony is not lost on me here
counselor boys
in terms of you criticizing those on the
one hand for being too slow
to respond and then seemingly
complaining for an overly
efficient response the second time
around thank you mr man
thank you councillor weston councillor
boys do you have a supplementary
question
yes i do mr mayor thank you and it's
interesting since the
discussion about procrastination took
place in the community have already
formed
anyway my supplementary question is
given that the one place
to which all online residents might
receive
regular communication from the leader is
via a blog on the borrower's website
might we have an assurance that going
forward postings will be made much more
frequently than recently when
during the current unprecedented crisis
there was almost
five months between post and thank you
mr mayor
yeah certainly mr mayor i'm happy to um
determine when i post those blogs and
counselor boys will be
more than aware that it is not the only
channel that we use as a council to
communicate with residents
but it's certainly a much more frequent
blog than residents ever had under the
previous administration
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
weston uh question number eight is
councillor but can he ask you to put
your
question now please
thank you uh mr mayor i think the uh
one of the questions was answered the
first one
um but they are i'll ask the question
again can the executive member for
environment and regulatory services
provide an update on current
consultation on the modal filters
at the longford park area of stratford
um wood councillor rad said executive
member like to respond
please thank you mr mayor and council
book for your question
uh as you've seen the quest uh the reply
in that respect are you happy if we move
to supplementary
oh do you like this one can you just
quickly go through it so that people
have an idea what the uh
what the response was thank you that's
fine
thank you uh that's what mr matt yes the
planters were installed on a template
basis
with the intention to carefully monitor
the impact
at the end of the year once the changes
had had a chance to bed in and following
the consultation
consider alternative locations or remove
the planters
were appropriate the position of the
planters
did make the through unattractive to
food traffic
but did allow a degree of flexibility
for local residents
wishing to exit onto king's road or
ajlane
however having listened to early
feedback following implementation from
residents of kenwood road
the world councillors in conjunction the
executive member from
air quality and climate change myself
agreed the planter should remain in
their current positions
but and in order to gain as many views
as possible
from the affected area that the
follow-up resident consultation
should be brought forward as such
residents have now received a letter
seeking views
on the way forward residents have been
asked to indicate whether they wish the
planters to remain as they are
to be removed completely or to retain
the planter on hillingham hillingdon
road but
relocate the planters on cromwell road
on norwood road in order to stop all
through routes
between king's road and slain in
addition
traffic counters have been being stated
in order to assess the impact on traffic
trials across the area
and emergency services have been
reconsulted to canvass their views
the closing date for residents responses
is friday the 18th
december following which a decision will
be
we made the strength of feeling in
response to the planters
and understand there are differing
opinions
on this matter as is often the case
when road layouts are changed however
the planters will be removed
if there is insufficient support for
them or relocated
should there be wider support to retain
them both in different locations
thank you okay councillor
do you have a supplementary question yes
i do thank you uh
wanted to say it mr mayor that many
residents in the longwood park area of
stratford have contacted us to say that
the first consultation period regarding
the
filters was not long enough uh that some
residents did not receive any
information on the consultation at all
the consultation was not easy to
complete online for those who actually
had internet access
and that equality yes
it's a question we know a supplementary
question okay i'll come to the question
there
now now there was a petition against the
measures
has received more than more signatures
than that number of residents who
expressed the desire for the traffic
calming
in the area through the first
consultation can the exec member resolve
the issue now by saving time
taxpayers funding and remove the
barriers
thank you mr mayor thanks for watching
thank you mr mayor i can have a great
deal what i said originally
mostly uh that this is one of the things
that was put on the common place
for the council when we look at active
travel schemes and it was one that
attracted
a lot of comments and indeed uh it is a
but one that actually had uh in the
order of some 300
responses to it some 50 turnout which is
actually really positive in terms of
responses
so it's one of the ones that we want to
go forward it is complicated
uh in terms of responses but in essence
two-thirds of the people that respond to
the first consultation
were keen for some sort of measures to
be taken and that was why
it was actually decided in consultation
with local members let's put this into
taunt one
obviously we are reconsulting looking at
this now obviously we can't take out
anything
until the consultation period is
finished as you know well no and that is
under
you know undertaking at this moment in
time i also do want to listen to those
views of people
and i need cancer but you may well have
seen uh some comments i've seen to
myself i've seen a mix of views myself
as i have local members
but we need we need to see the much
wider mix of people but as obviously
many people who may be happy with it
scheme i'm not actually going to
object to something in that century so
we need to get that wider perspective
before i make a decision on it but it
will be the
decision of the local people and i'd
like to assure all members
as well that obviously that that measure
will be in place during this
consultation
to ensure that it's only the views of
people living within
that area that actually be taking into
account in that respect
so with that mr mayor i'll leave it up
obviously it counts for what would like
to discuss this further
any point after this meeting i'm quite
happily uh uh engaged with him on that
respect obviously the views of
our presence will be paramount in this
thank you
thank you council i'd said question
number nine councillor morgan the first
of your questions please
thank you mr mayor and to ask the
executive member
um following the rejection of the much
unloved greater manchester spatial
framework by stockport council last week
can the executive member for housing and
regeneration provide the council with an
update on
progress with trafford's local plan
that's the right would you like to
respond
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
morgan again the answer has been
published on the website
um i've been sent to councillor morgan
i'm happy to answer in person should you
wish
but uh if not i'm happy to also move to
supplementary
council morgan would you like to move to
your supplementary question
thanks thank you mr mayor yes i've seen
uh the answer
uh council right um i thank the
executive member for his response
but i don't see how we can consult local
uh residents without full understanding
the council's position on the gms gmsf
um so can i ask the executive member why
we can't have a full debate now
on its merits and many flaws of the
greater manchester spatial framework
like stockport did only a week ago
thank you mr councillor wright
thank you councillor morgan we are we we
have an agenda item later on in the
agenda which is to do with the gms
efforts i think it's best left
until that point uh frankly i may i just
point out as well this evening mr mayor
um how divided the tory opposition seems
to be
on this uh situation um we have
councillor anthony who believes we
should be as pro housing growth as
possible
councillor kerry who is against this
because of a lack of school places
and councillor morgan who doesn't love
the gs gmsf and has no plan
to tackle our housing shortage what are
shambles mr mayor
thank you mr mayor that's the right um
question number ten councillor morgan
your second
question please thank you mr matt um can
i
um ask the executive member for housing
and regeneration
to provide the council with an update on
the status of the hail
and sale more place plans
councillor wright would you like to
respond thank you mr mayor thank you
councillor morgan
again the answer has been published on
the website and i believe council morgan
may have seen the answer so i'm happy to
move to supplementary should that be
required
thank you have you have you seen the
answer on the website
i have thank you mr mayor yeah that was
a very quick response from uh council
rice i think it might be an i.t uh item
um i thank the executive member for his
response um
can i ask him to tell to update the
council on what the total cost of the
plan has been
to date and the total and participated
cost of the
um plan through to fruition
thank you councilman i do not have those
figures to hand but i'm more than happy
to write to you with those figures
as soon as possible
thank you question number 11 councillor
evans the final question
please thank you mr mayor
mayor takes opportunity and we have the
conservative group to welcome you to
your new role and wish you the best for
coming at 18 months
not been an opportunity to do that so
welcome and we're very pleased
that you're there so thank you on to the
question
as the leader of the council now has
responsibility the sustainability and
climate
change and the clean air plan uh can the
leader tell us
how many no2x agencies they were in
trafford
recorded at air quality monitoring sites
in 2019
will the leader like to respond zero mr
man
chancellor evans do you have a
supplementary question thank you mr
mayor
so air quality in trafford uh the
exceedance is recorded at zero
and considering the original fact of
fact-finding consultation only garnered
182 respondents in trafford
and an old polluting vehicle being there
anything other than three years old
today there are likely to be in excess
of seven and a half thousand vans alone
seventy five thousand cross gm seven and
a half thousand in
trafford and the cost will be in excess
of ten
thousand pounds per advantage after any
grant
what message would the council of
western like to send to the winter
cleaners decorators florists plasterers
and other trades who he and the mayor of
gm will be
plunging into debt of at least 10 000
pounds
per van per business
councilor weston thank you mr mayor i
would advise them
to if they have not already fed into the
consultation process which has closed
to send an email to clean airgmfcom.com
to make sure their views are known
because the role that i now have along
with the mayor of greater manchester
is to lobby the conservative government
responsible for directing
all boroughs in greater manchester
because it is not great to manchester
who have um decided to act on this
although i believe it is the right thing
to do nor is it greater manchester who
are compelled to act on this mr mayor
but the individual boroughs including
trafford
regardless of those exceedance numbers
quoted by
councillor evans so what i would say is
that if they have not made their views
known they should feed
in to that consultation email address
which does remain open
in order that we can build the most
compelling case possible
for the conservative government who have
directed us to implement this cassc
clean air zone
to give us the funding that we require
because thus far we have received i
believe 41 million
out of a total ask of 165 million
and that given the impact on businesses
that councillor evans has just
highlighted
is absolutely disgusting and i'm not
surprised
to hear these sorts of words and
rhetoric coming out of council evans
mouth on this given the nonsense that
we've had from greater manchester
conservatives
on this item calling it a congestion tax
in spite of their own minister standing
up in parliament and telling one of
their mps that this is not
a congestion tax and given that they are
claiming
some utter nonsense on a on a what
should be
a positive scheme if your
government funded councillor evans and
what i say to you
when you complain about how far this
scheme goes is that your party is
all over the place on this issue i've
got you here saying
oh this goes way too far and businesses
need to be supported i've got your
minister
saying that we need to be very clear
that it's not a congestion tax i've got
one of your local election candidates
emailing me saying that we should be
charging for all polluting vehicles
including private vehicles so what an
absolute joke you are on this councillor
evans the fact
is that the funding issue sits squarely
with your government
as does the decision to implement this
scheme so i suggest you turn your fire
and your eye
upon them councillor evans because the
extent of the funding package that we
receive
is entirely dependent on them getting on
and giving us what we need to protect
the very businesses
you claim to care about thank you mr
mayor
thank you um that's the end of the
questions
item number three is a petition
regarding secondary school's admission
process
for 2021 which has received 547
signatures in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
the petition organizer miss claire beale
will be invited to speed to the petition
for five minutes
following which it will be debated by
the council for a maximum
of 15 minutes the group leaders have
agreed that speeches will
be limited to one member from each of
the groups
as there is only 15 minutes allowed each
will be allocated 3 minutes
and 45 seconds following debate the
debate the leader of the council will
then summarize the council's response
if council consents to the arrangements
i will now invite
miss beale to introduce the petition
you i have council's consent
i think i have council's comments
[Music]
hi hi hi
thank you miss beale would you like to
speak
hello
crew
hello sorry i don't know what happened
there um
thank you mr mayor um i really
appreciate the opportunity to talk today
about this this um this issue
um just to be clear obviously this isn't
a case for against grammar schools
which we know is an extremely emotive
issue in trafford and this is just to
ensure that this year we're able to make
the best decision for our children
and i also appreciate that this is a
extremely complex system and the
practicalities of any change i'm
requesting is not
it's far from simple however i'm sure
you'd agree it's so important for our
children both in terms of their
education
and even more importantly their
happiness and emotional well-being
during their school years and beyond um
i think
they will be 10 years ago the head
teacher at my daughter's school i should
describe this as the last big decision
we actually make for our children
after that they go on their own way so i
think that's probably just a
saw how important it is and so with this
in mind i'd just like to make it clear
why
i and many other year six children as
you can tell by the petition numbers
and feel that the ability to change our
preferences is so important
in addition to the supplementary
preference places has been made
available which is
you know a good step forward but just
not quite enough
um to enable us to make the right
decision on our children's behalf
so if you can imagine we essentially had
to make multiple theoretical decisions
rather than being able to focus on the
definite options available to us
and make the firm decisions on this
basis this was compounded by the fact we
hadn't been able to view any of the
secondary schools at any open days this
year
which i completely appreciate is the
same circumstances for all the parents
however that did make the practicalities
of making multiple
decisions even more difficult
many parents including myself my husband
would much prefer to send their children
to a school with at least one friend if
at all possible
and particularly if the school in
question is a bus or tram ride away from
their home
currently the way the weed that we were
expected to make the decisions
this was impossible to predict given the
lack of knowledge about the exam
outcomes for everybody not just our own
children
and it was scenario planning to the
extreme and i would describe it as
trying to complete a jigsaw without all
the pieces
and for an example of this i know of one
little boy him and all his friends
all did the ultranam and the sale exam
and
all his friends passed for ultringham
and he actually didn't pass voting will
pass a sale on his own
and was absolutely distorted the idea
that he has to be he's going to sail on
his own he would much prefer
to attend the local comprehensive school
with some of his football team
that again is knowledge that was
impossible to have
before without without the exam results
it might have been in some cases i have
heard this um
in my personal exams for the results um
when i demonstrate the scoring question
isn't actually the right place for the
child
um i know one family last year whose son
passed through stratford exam
by a very small margin and they use the
results to come to this
and send into ashton that's the best
place for him
and you know that's that's just one
example and there's another example
which i hadn't actually considered when
i submitted the position one family were
unaware there was a difference between
the martial cell and stratford
and then only puts that down on their
form unfortunately the boy only passes
stratford which he now can't attend
knowing the voters vote results in
advance would obviously have avoided
this
the situation with regards to covert has
exacerbated this
as i i'm going to understand that head
teachers would normally do a session for
years
parents and offer practical advice on
completing the form in the process
which can be very confusing and i know
certainly from my point of view that
didn't
happen and i don't believe it happened
for a number of other schools too
so that's sort of the reasons why um
from what i can understand of the
process each school actually receives
every application where they've been
listed
as one of the preferences regardless of
the order of those preferences
so a school might receive one
application where the number one on the
order of preference another way the
number five but they're not aware of
that so they have to rank all the
children regardless
of of whether you know against their
published admission criteria
so actually with this in mind and that's
not to distract
from the knowledge this must be a huge
undertaking for the admissions section
each year
but given the unprecedented
circumstances in which we find ourselves
would it not be possible to change the
preference order
before the date the bank fails are
returned to the local authority
without this being classed as a late
submission i do appreciate this wouldn't
help the poor family who realized that
who hadn't realized the past mark for
sale and stratford were different
which is unfortunate um
i don't believe many parents would want
to change their submission
however i think it would be invaluable
for the few as it would ensure that the
emotion on academic welfare of their
children for the next five years
and it's a really big decision um and i
think that's probably
shown by the father other brothers with
selection exams for example berkshire
and buckinghamshire
have changed their process to allow
changes to the preferences once the
results were known this must be because
they thought it was the right thing to
do for the children involved
and that's that's probably it i think
so thank you thank you miss beale um
councillorna carter as a lead member for
education
i invite you now to respond on behalf of
the labour group
uh thank you mr mayor and um thank you
to
claire for bringing a petition because
we don't often get them at council
so and it's quite an interesting process
for us all
this year the department for education
issued guidance for grammar schools and
local authorities which strongly advise
that the tests
should be moved back to late october and
i think council's aware that as an
authority we don't administer these
tests but we do oversee the admissions
process
so this meant that parents had to submit
their applications for secondary school
before they knew the result of the test
to make sure we did not disadvantage
families the dfe asked local authorities
to allow at least one
additional preference on the application
form and to advise families to use those
preferences to apply for non-selective
schools
we thought carefully about how to
protect the interests of both schools
and families
and decided to allow an additional three
preferences
making eight preferences in total so
for councillors who aren't as familiar
with the process you if you wanted to go
to grammar school you would put the five
or six grammar schools you wanted
and then you would put wellington and
then you would put sale high and then
you would put stratford high
or whatever your combination was and it
was made really clear to parents if the
child didn't pass for grammar
those five choices would be disallowed
and you would then just revert to your
top um
priority of high school um
so 456 of the 3087
trafford applicants took advantage and
they did use all eight choices
each year all local authorities must
formulate and publish a scheme to
coordinate admission arrangements for
school
in accordance with the school admissions
code and the closing day is statutory
and it's the 31st of october
this is set in law and it can't be
changed
we receive applications from other local
authorities last year
we had applications from over 35
other local authorities to come to a
traffic school
and so we have to coordinate our
admissions around the national day which
is the 31st of october
your petition requested that we allowed
parents to amend
the order of secondary school
preferences once the results were known
and it's noted that a few authorities
did do
do that they did move that date but it
wasn't possible within trafford's
legally determined schemes as our
processes commenced earlier
and we have to send the list to the
other local authorities on the 19th of
november
so if we go to your petition whilst you
say 546 people
from 464 addresses did sign the petition
16 of these signatories lived outside of
trafford
one lifts in america and 73 signatories
did not have
children at any school in any age group
in trafford
210 of the people who signed the
petition
do have year six children so it's those
children this affected
at all the premier school results are
known now the last results were sent out
on the 29th of october and the number of
parents that have requested a late
change has been eight
parents so far and actually none of them
relate to the service
the the circumstances cited in your
report
and one of the families only put grammar
schools
and didn't put any higher scores and
then the child didn't pass so that's one
of the families
and i i've been in contact with three of
the out of v8
and the guidance was very clear and
virtually all parents followed the
process
so in many instances late applications
and changes can be accommodated without
disadvantaging another child
and to be honest when it can be done it
will be done
um if it can't be done parents have the
right of the appeal and they're not
limited to considering the published
arrangements
they can consider exceptional
circumstances and overturn the decision
of
admission authority in addition waiting
lists must run until at least the end of
the autumn term
and many schools including the very most
popular schools do see
movement in the allocations after the
1st march
as families move in and out of areas and
we've also seen families choosing to
home school or
circumstances change we are satisfied
councilman carter we need to
wind up here with
satisfied the arrangements we've made
comply with statutory guidance
and provide ample opportunity to meet
the needs of families
without contravening the already agreed
and published arrangements
these were made in coordination with the
greater manchester area to carry on
effectively
i will not advantage or disadvantage any
applicant
over any other thank you thank you
councillor carter
i understand councilman carey is going
to respond on behalf of the conservative
group
am i correct uh without counsel for
caring
yes thank you mr mayor and uh thanks
claire you made some really good points
in your petition and your speech is
quite daunting speaking in front of
everyone here i thought council carts
gave a really good response there
as well and we do live in the best part
of the country for education we have
amazing schools and an amazing choice
and and as a group we support
any move that makes this administ uh
admission process simpler and
easier to use and we would encourage the
council to further engage with the uh
people who brought the petition
uh to have an admission system that
works for them and all the young people
across trafford
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
i invite councillor brophy to respond on
behalf of the liberal democrats group
[Music]
thank you mr mayor can everybody hear me
can we can counsel abroad okay so thank
you to everyone who's spoken so far
and for the information provided by
councillor carter and particularly the
the parents who've come together to do
the petition and the
and the speeches we've just heard so the
liberal democrat group wish to support
um families in trafford we want to
express that support
because families are facing unique
challenges this year due to co-vid19
and under normal circumstances parents
and children will be able to choose
secondary schools after all the
information is available to them
including
the results of entrance exams this year
we've got unprecedented circumstances
for all our residents including the
parents and young people
so we must be willing if we can to
change time frames to allow for fairness
in our local school system
and the petition seeks to allow families
to tweak school
choices to best suit families and young
people in their care
so in support of this petition i think
it's widely known that
more would have signed this have been
known about it wasn't that well known by
many parents
and children who are out of school in
this preceding term
and they really want to do their best to
support their children's education
key workers are going to be uniquely
affected as well
so usually the system does allow for
parents and children to have several
weeks to decide
when they know the outcome of what the
11 plus is for their children
this year those choices have had to be
made blindly
um as the results at the time were
unknown so according to the trafford
schools admission website
that parents would have looked at it
does say the system cannot be
adjusted that any application submitted
um after 31st of october 2020 is late
and will only be considered after the
applications received on time
has been processed so so we know that
not many people will have taken that
route given
of what it said so it's again it's a
very difficult year there are some
children that will be significantly
impacted
by this and we feel the system should be
fairer and more transparent
from a resident's point of view we know
that march from one exam can be
different
as as the speakers have outlined um you
know
different schools do have different
marks and not all parents know that
parents have told me that this year
they've been unable to view schools meet
with staff
and consider their child's options um
before the results come in that that's
the usual thing
and there's a real example that was
given to me recently
about parents of twins who passed
different 11 plus
exams and and now if that in this
scenario
what would happen if they weren't able
to see the results before they came in
so it seems unfair that even parents of
twins who might want to keep their their
children together and the twins might
want to stay together
we're not allowing them to make that
choice to stay at the same school
so in conclusion the liberal democrat
group we wholeheartedly support this
petition for the following reasons we
feel it's unfair on parents and children
as this will impact on their future
choices
we also think it might lead to a number
of appeals
and which again could cause more
administrative work for
the council and importantly will be
distressing for children and uncertain
to parents as well
if we have the opportunity we should
rectify the situation before any further
harm is done
give parents and children the right to
resubmit their preferences
now the results are available which for
some individuals
you need to wind up please i am for some
individuals my
impact on the entire school career um so
in conclusion
we think it's the right thing to do and
the liberal democrats are supporting the
parents who brought forward this
petition
thank you councillor brophy can i invite
councillor coggins on behalf of the
green party to respond
yes thank you chair and thank you to uh
claire for bringing the petition
and organizing it and speaking to
council
and i'm sorry to hear of the incredible
difficulties
i know families have experienced this
year with with the system and trying to
make these choices without being able to
visit schools
it's it's them really mind-blowing how
difficult that must have been
and it's i know i've had very detailed
responses from the officers um
in the schools team and and um
discussions with councillor carter and i
know that it's a very complex issue
and the council has had to work within
the regulatory framework they were given
which is
is a difficult thing and it sounds like
very few families are now affected and i
really hope that the council will be
able to work with them and support
those children and families and and i
know that they're committed to doing
that in whatever way they can
and to consider any powers they have to
help due to exceptional circumstances
uh within the legal constraints they
have um and i hope that that you and
your your your friends and others
affected claire and managed to get your
children into the school that works for
them and where you're all happy
thank you thank you councillor coggins
finally will the leader of the council
summarize for the council
and our guest what will now happen with
the petition
thank you mr mayor before i do so um i
had hope the monitoring officer might
say a little to us about the
legal framework in which we're operating
um around this issue if that would be
acceptable to you mr matt
um yes mr mayor i think the position
has actually been covered in the
um original speech that was made by uh
councillor carter on this matter
the position is that every local
authority does have to publish a
theme um in accordance with the school's
admissions code in each year
and the um closing date for applications
under our scheme is the 31st of october
and it does mean that applications
considered after that are perceived
after that
have been considered as late
applications
and that's because of the complex piece
of this system that we were
under um and uh trafford's legally
determined
scheme has to be is very closely worked
out
in accordance with the some 35
other councils that we um
have to coordinate with um in order to
um make placements on an annual basis so
in this particular instance that the
council is constrained by
um its scheme and by the need to work
with other local authorities there's a
legal restriction around
what it can and cannot do in terms of
moving some of
thank you councillor weston thank you
mr mayor i think um that was that was a
helpful explanation
from jane just to have um the
independent legal advice there which
does set out the challenge that we have
in terms of considering the art of the
possible here which is that in short
there is a legal description
to us um going about this in the way
that the petitioners would have
requested
in the statutory and legally we we are
required to treat
applications coming in after the
deadline as late applications
um incredibly sympathetic to the stress
and strain that parents have come under
through this
um and there is perhaps a piece of work
that we need to do
in terms of making sure that parents are
aware that the past marks differ
by school because with respect that is
not a covert issue
so that surely will be an issue that we
need to
write moving forward um to avoid any
confusion
in the system and any unfortunate
consequences from that mr mayor
um but i certainly think that there um
is a piece of work for us to do now with
the eight families who have
um been affected by this we are hopeful
that we will be able to
accommodate those those children in the
schools of their choice that's not
something that we can guarantee
councillor carter's already been in
contact with a number of those families
and we will continue to work with them i
think that it's a really important issue
that's come before
council tonight but it is one that has
largely
worked itself out as time has moved on
that's not to say
that there haven't been issues that's
not to say it hasn't been difficult and
that's not to say that we still don't
need to do everything that we can
to work with those eight families mr
mayor but but i certainly think that
um it's important to recognize that
there were legal constraints here
prohibit
prohibiting us from acting as the
petitioners would have
requested that we do so thank you mr man
thank you councillor weston thank you
miss beale for bringing that
important issue to us um item number
four
is the asset investment strategy i will
now invite councillor ross
executive member for finance and
governance to introduce the strategy
which has been referred to been referred
to the council by the executive
councilor ross thank you mr mayor this
item
formed part of recommendations made at
the executive meeting held on the 12th
of october
our strategy promotes our strategic
priorities creating an income stream to
support our local services
it's also shows due regard to risk and
our sign-off process remains in place
in addition page 3 of the cb cbre report
sets out further updates including our
emphasis on regeneration
and social economic and environmental
benefits
to the um to the process please note
that high risk investments will not be
included in the
in the investment strategy page 10 of
the report uh
cb re report sets up more information on
our criteria
which mirror our strategic priorities
there's also a list of them
preferred project attributes i'm asking
for council
to agree to the updated asset investment
strategy thank you mr matt
thank you councillor ross do we have a
second please
that can do it mr matt thank you
councillor weston
um do any members wish to speak to this
item
councilor meyers i think wants to speak
yes thank you mr mayor um i hear what um
council ross has just said that the
conservative group will be voting
against this strategy
as set out in the report tonight we
recognize the figure
of 7.4 million generated to support the
revenue budget in 2020
2021 is welcome but the scale of
borrowing during a global pandemic
especially in the retail property is
very risky
the collapse of the arcadia group and
debenhams
are symptomatic very of the difficult
times
that retailers face in coming to coming
to terms with the change in market
conditions
the covid emergency has resulted in a
dramatic shift
of consumer spend away from the high
speed and
in towards online shopping many
retailers are tied to
unaffordable leases and business rates
bills which will just drag them into
insolvency
in consequence we're going to see more
vacant retail premises
of more overvalued assets in the recent
spending review the chancellor rishi
sunek
announced that local authorities will no
longer be able to borrow money
from the public works loans board in
order to invest in commercial property
solely for generating profit and if you
analyze the figures that have been
published
208 million pounds on our current
investment which works out at nearly two
two-thirds of the investment portfolio
appears to be aimed to produce
revenue rather than regeneration of
trafford
the strategy therefore needs to be
reviewed in the light of that
announcement
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
myers councillor new gross you'd like to
speak
thank you mr mayor um so i
just wanted to um ask uh on the
new strategy um on
page 23 um regarding
uh can the consideration
if fair value could drop below borrowing
now i remember uh warning uh councillors
back in the uh full council um
the budget council in in february last
year
that should the ba shock to the economic
system
that our investment may drop below
the value that we spent on it i'm asking
um
what is the new value has our assets
dropped below the money that we borrowed
to speculate
on thank you
thank you councillor new gross um
councillor evans you want to make a
comment
thank you thank you mr mayor now
conscious that i'm bound by the
confidentiality agreement i sit on this
board
um but i would just like to put on
record i have
severe reservations but conscious of uh
my
my position on the board i have severe
reservations and support
councilmembers comments
okay any other members wishing to
comment
um is that agreed do we need to go to a
vote or
i'm looking for advice documentary
questions
from the green room
council coddling do you want to comment
thank you just
just briefly and i i i wanted to welcome
these changes
and the green group uh understands
why we have uh these investments is not
necessarily a decision we would have
made
but i think this strategy is stronger
than the previous strategy
the inclusion of the preferred project
attributes gives
some semblance of an ethical framework
for what we can and can't invest in and
and so i think that this is an
improvement on what we've previously
seen
thank you thank you councillor coggins
okay i'm going to invite everybody to
vote have the facilities
uh available for people to vote
can someone advise me of that are we
point of order mr mayor i was asking a
question under 10.1 of uh
of uh councillor ross
um councilwoman
can i can i say to you and to everybody
that um it's a bit complicated for me to
manage the chat
and uh and the discussion and if members
wish to speak if
if possible they could indicate it um um
through through through the video screen
that would be helpful to me
um councilor ross would you like to
respond to councillor newgross
um thank you mr with your permission
i'll just respond to the
the three comments and questions that i
had if that's okay i will be brief
um first of all to councillor myers and
thank you for
your contribution obviously page 17 and
18 of the
report shows our updated criteria and
the regard that we have
to risk because of the covid19 situation
and i can just repeat again
we are looking at regeneration prospects
particularly within this borough as part
of this revised strategy
and councilor new growth we'll get that
figure to you i'll ask one of the
officers to supply that figure
the door is always open for you though
to actually engage with us and this
strategy
um that is the most constructive thing
that you could do and would be
beneficial to the
the council going forward and finally
council coping thank you very much for
your comments and uh and for agreeing
with the um with the um
the semantics and well with the report i
should say
thank you
[Music]
okay i'm seeing comments about the
voting
experience and it's not been as good as
as good as we'd like so i'm going to try
and
okay we're going to read we're going to
redo the vote
so we just um just hang fire for a
moment and we'll see that box will
appear again
can everybody vote
[Music]
uh
excuse me there are there are
about three people who who haven't voted
yet
if they could um ensure that they
uh submit the vault at the bottom of the
screen
okay that's been carried that vote has
been carried
okay we'll go to item number five
revenue budget the council is formally
required to approve the addition
of public health monies to the revenue
budget as referred from the executive
meeting on the 23rd of november
and i invite councillor ross executive
member for finance and government
governance to move that now councillor
ross
thank you mr mayor you've taken almost
all my words out of uh
out of my mouth there um yes basically
we're looking to increase
the uh public health budget by 261
000 for this year which brings our total
gross revenue budget to 170 million 5
million
520 000. um this was referenced in the
period
six out turn budget monitoring report
sorry
um that was discussed at executive last
month
um is that seconded uh yes mr mayor i
formally seconded it
you council slater do any members wish
to speak to this item
i've managed to look into the chat and i
can't see anything there
so no members wish to speak sorry mr
mayor can i speak i did
i did try and put something in the chat
i think it's been uh
superseded by another another
contribution okay mr mayor
we are as a conservative group we're in
favor of this this motion
thank you thank you councillor myers
anybody else wishing to speak
okay is that agreed i
[Music]
that's fine everybody thank you um item
number six
council tax support scheme can i invite
councillor ross
executive member for finance and
governance to introduce the proposed
scheme for
2021-22 which has been referred to the
council
by the executive councilor ross thank
you mr mayor each year we're required to
formally approve our council tax support
scheme
um we propose we adopt the scheme
currently in operation
updating it in line with national
benefits
thank you council ross do i have a
second i can build mr ma
thank you councillor western any members
wishing to speak to this item
councillor myers yes thank you mr mayor
um can i just say that
trafford continued to have one of the uh
the best and
well-functioning uh support schemes
in the north west of england in fact not
in the whole country
and we are as conservative were fully
supportive of this uh
this action thank you thank you
councillor myers
any other members wishing to speak
is that item agreed i
i i i thank you
thank you item number seven statement of
licensing
licensing policy 2021-26
may invite councillor freeman executive
member responsible
at the time this report was written to
introduce the policy
which has also been referred to the
council by the executive
councillor freeman uh thank you mr mayor
the council requires repair consult on
unpublished statement of licensing
policy every five years and our last
review occurred in 2016.
the summary section of the paper
outlines the fine main the five main
purposes of the policy
as a result of consultation between 29th
to june 20 to 18
9 20 changes in legislation and best
practice our policy has been updated
some features of the update
are ensuring local ward counters are
consulted upon
applications for new premises license or
full variation applications
expanded detail on measures to promote
the licensing objectives
a section on child sexual exploitation
expectations for white-collar boxing
events counter-terrorism measures
guidance on the immigration act
and details of a pre-application
consultation service
the review has also considered whether
or not to keep cumulative
impact areas for ultraman cell town
centres this form part of the
consultation
such an area is a designated zone where
evidence has indicated that the number
type or density of licensed premises is
impacting adversely upon
licensing objectives namely crime of
disorder public safety
public nuisance and the protection of
children from harm
originally a concept sale and ultra were
designated in our policy in 2000 2016
as such places and now form part of what
is known as our special saturation
policy
the police and crime match from 2017
giving punitive impact areas
a legal footing as a result of the
consultation and the very fact
the saturation policy has never been
used to object to the grant or variation
of premises license applications in
either sale or altering them
a new statement of licensing policy
removes this special licensing policy
on cumulative impact for both ultron and
sale
and this is the most significant change
to the policy
and what basically asked council to
approve the report tonight
which is before them and there's a false
statement of the revised policy as
appendix
f thank you very much mr mayor thank you
councillor freeman
is there a second death please seconded
mr mayor
thank you councillor radshead do any
members wish to speak
to this item
i'll take that as a no is that item
agreed
hi
[Music]
hi hi all the eyes we've got all the
eyes that's good that is agreed then
thank you
item number eight great for manchester
spatial framework
council will have noted the report
circulated as an addendum to the report
originally proposed
this explains that as a consequence of
stockport council's decision
not to approve the plan for consultation
and submission
the matter effectively cannot be decided
upon
at this meeting tonight therefore it is
to be withdrawn
i now invite the leader to move that the
new item
that the item be withdrawn councillor
weston
thank you mr mayor um i so move thank
you
is that seconded mr mayer
thank you councillor hines um
accordingly i move that we now proceed
to the next item of business
and i call oh it has been seconded if
anyone wishes to speak
uh to this item can they
we can have some discussion on this but
it's on the withdrawal and not the gmss
any councils need to
speak to this item may do so but we are
talking about the withdrawal
not gmsf any councils wishing to speak
on a point of order mr mayor in
accordance with
um the model procedural rules from the
constitution
section 12 j i move that the question is
now put without further debate
yeah we're going to move to that we're
advised council of western is absolutely
correct and we're going to move to the
next item thank you everybody
um item number nine is motions
this evening four motions have been
listed on the summons
in the order that they were
[Music]
you are i'm being advised that i need to
ask the question
of members this evening do we agree to
the withdrawal
of the item on the agenda
hi
thank you everybody i'll now proceed to
item number nine
which is motions this evening four
motions have been listed on the summons
in
in the order they were received
motion 9a the motion regarding the
proposed changes
changes to the all-age transport policy
is to be moved by council ransack
thanks for answer thank you very much um
mr man this is a relatively simple
motion and short motion because
there's two things and that i remember
from my previous
time in administration around schools in
general the first of which that all
members
of this council on a number of occasions
reiterated
stated and made public their support
not just for our schools in trafford but
for the school system
that we have a secondary level education
and that is welcome actually and i hope
that members therefore will realize that
the changes that are
proposed in the all-age travel policy
in the consultation undermine that
support for our school system
because they start to remove choice and
from parents about how and where they
send their children
to school the second point i remember
well is that whenever we discuss home to
school transport which is an extremely
uh sensitive uh topic and i remember a
comment in the council chamber from
councillor bennett actually said if we
cannot transport our children to school
we might as well all go home and here we
are again with some proposals to change
the consultation the policy and for a
relatively minor
sum of money i think thirty thousand
pounds um in the party and forty five
000 pound
uh full year effect saving well we know
um
that that in in the council's uh budget
um yes
in the challenges that the authority
faces today
is not insignificant but it is
surmountable and it is something that
the council could choose
to do if it wanted to do this and
ultimately this is about
uh choice and respecting choice in our
schools
system and what this change which would
do is introduce parents
to additional costs just because they
want to send their children
out to school of their choice and it
will margin and it will greatly
impact parents of children marginally
above the free school's meal
threshold with uh or with one more
child or parents a child that i saw
again or with more than one child and
parents who already have a child
at school and a wish for a sibling to
attend the same school
so what we're calling for in this motion
and this evening is to say that
if we believe as i know we all do in
uh making sure that our school system is
supported if we believe
in being able to ensure that our
children in traffic are able to have
choices about where they attend
and if we believe in social mobility
what what the motion says is that the
council resolves
um to take this no further and and
therefore i move the motion
thank you is the motion seconded
secondly mr mayor and reserve the right
to speak
thank you councillor evans do any
members wish to speak to this item
councillor carter's indicated
um thank you mr mayor um currently this
is out for consultation and that
consultation is open until the 10th of
january
so in many ways i don't want to
prejudice the consultation
but in light of this motion i will
detail what the thinking is behind it
we have to provide travel assistance to
eligible children who meet the national
criteria
and attend their nearest qualifying
school
this takes into account the distance
traveled the family income
how safe the route is and whether the
child has special needs or a disability
the nearest qualifying school is the
school nearest to where you live that
has places
if parents choose a more distant school
then we do not intend to provide a
travel pass
unless the family has a low income we
will continue to fund the 40 percent
most economically disadvantaged families
so that's
as councillor honestly says families on
free school meals its universal credit
is also on working family tax credit
up to an income of 16 190 pounds
i appreciate that still really low but
your government set the threshold
so currently that would include that
number
will now be 16 families we're going to
continue to fund
um which is above statutory requirements
the bus passes are currently allocated
to children who do not pass for their
nearest grammar but they do pass for
another grammar in the borough
these travel passes cost of 378 pounds a
year
and this change of policy will currently
affect 124 families
there are currently 8036 pupils in
traffic grammar schools
so we're looking at 1.5 percent of
pupils here
currently 56 of the passes we issue are
to families who live in the wa
14 and 15 postcodes to be absolutely
clear that 70 out of 124 live in
altringham hale and bowdoin
40 out of 124 live in m33
m41 instant and sale postcodes
and according to the adaki register of
income deprivation
which impacts children 73 of the
families we fund
live in the 30 percent least
disadvantaged areas in
england we do not fund families who
choose a high school
further away or who choose an out of by
replacement
unless they are on low income council
can clearly see that this current policy
benefits one group of children
above others and this is unfair this
policy is a direct result of our
two-tier education system
and in order to level up all our
children we do not believe we could
continue to pay for families that can
afford to pay for themselves
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor carter councilman
minis i'm advised that we're running
late on time so can you um
make your comments within a one minute
time frame please and that goes for
everybody now we need to do
just one minute for our comments please
thank you thank you mr mayor
um so the current transport policy has
shortcomings
and the liberal democrats feel the
consultation paper
does not address these and if this
consultation is to continue
we will be calling for all children who
attend special schools
to be provided transport outside a 1.5
mile radius this would be down from your
blanket uh
two mile for primary and three mile for
secondary school policy
um the reasons are the many children who
attend
actually mainstream primary schools uh
travel up to 1.5 miles
uh students who attend a special special
schools
uh regularly travel much further
and so a fellow resident of timperley
has a daughter with disabilities and
attended
a nearby pick to school when her
daughter transitioned to brentwood they
found that they suddenly fell in this
three-mile
rule problem uh and it applied to them
and they leave
councilmember i won't be long
compliments i really have to stop you
there we are down to a minute each for
commenting
i know i
though you have had a minute counseling
this with time when you're here it
doesn't seem like that when you're
talking i'm sure but
i'm sure you have had a minute
councillor coggins you have one
that's very unfair i'm afraid it's very
unfair to be challenging somebody's
ability to count a minute
counsellor minutes can we
can we move on please can we move on
councillor minish wants to make an issue
of that she's quite happy
i'm quite happy for her to contact me
outside of the meeting councillor
coggins you have one minute thank you
thank you chair um this motion is two
sentences long and we in the green party
have
have pointed out before that we really
believe in uh doing grown-up politics
and we take our policy uh writing roles
seriously
we're not happy to vote on a two-line
sketchy statement that could have
unintended consequences if we vote one
way or the other so we'll be abstaining
tonight
thank you thank you councillor coggins
councillor morgan you'd like to come in
thank you mayor and i will be uh very
brief um i'm disappointed
um for some of councillor carter's
comments um
in her response i live in a wa-14
postcode and i represent wa15 postcard
and
there are areas of significant affluence
but it's not
a universal area of significance and
there are significant deprivation in
both of those postcode areas
and i think i'm just supportive of what
council and said this is
if this council supports the policies
that we we have
repeatedly said across all of the groups
um
about our special education system i
think
for such a small fraction of money um
which could
there are savings that the council
haven't looked at i really do think
the council needs to think again um and
i really urge all
councillors to support our motion
tonight thank you thank you councillor
morgan
councillor heinz likes to comment i
thank you mr mer just very briefly in
view of the time i just wanted to
fully support the comments of um
councillor
carter and this policy
this proposal is just a proposal at this
stage which is out for consultation the
decision
will be made after the consultation and
will fully take into account
um the responses that we receive
as part of that and also to reiterate
that this will not impact
um families um with low incomes who
are in who are eligible for free school
meals thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor hines councillor
evans
thank you miss mayor i was going to
speak about choice but we've had a
a discussion earlier this evening about
spending
probably somewhere between 50 and 100
000 on a mail out to our residents when
we could have done it with volunteers
we need to be constructive here to give
that choice to the parents
on the margins we've seen the passion
from mrs beale tonight
about choice it's all about choice we
need
we should see no more of this it is it's
embarrassing that we are
talking about we have challenges let's
face those challenges but let's not
remove the choice
from our parents and our families
thank you councillor evans councillor
acton
thank you mr mayor this is presently out
for
consultation and in terms of choice
our aim is to be fair and equitable to
every child in trafford whichever school
they attend
whether that be a grammar school or a
high school
the outcome of the consultation will
help significantly
in how we can ensure that fairness and
equality of opportunities actually
exist so with that um
you know i support uh what what would
what has been trying to be done and it
is consultation just remember
thank you councillor axton councillor
haddad you'd like to comment
[Music]
you're on you're on mute counselor her
dad
sorry can you hear me yeah thank you mr
mayor
um i too would like to um say this is
very disappointing and
seems um totally um
inflexible at this time when you know
there's so many uncertainties due to the
pandemic
and we should be supporting choice and
families and i hope
that the consultation will reveal
the strength of feeling about choice and
supporting children to get to the
schools
that they want to go to thank you mr
mayor
thank you councillor haddad i have no
other members wishing to speak
i'm not advised if anybody does please
sorry mr man my hand is up
in the uh panelists column right
thank you councillor weston uh my uh
facility for that isn't working i'm
advised but you are welcome
very welcome to speak councillor wesley
thank you mr master just very briefly
this is out for
consultation but i do have to say that
arguments about parental choice
when only wishing to apply that to
parents who are sending their children
to grammar school
does seem slightly unfair as an approach
to me and if that was the concern of the
conservative group
i failed to see why it wasn't their
policy for all children
in trafford mr mayor so these are um as
far as i'm concerned crocodile tears as
to councillor
um morgan's comments about
um the four and wa14 one five postcodes
counselor carter did not say that
everybody living there was wealthy she
said they were in the top 30
that is fact but we are protecting not
just those eligible for free school
meals
but those earning within the the next
20 percent of people also so this will
not be
what councilor evans referred to as
parents around the margins that is just
nonsense this is about a level playing
field so that all parents have choice
not just the parents whose children
pass for grammar school this is about
making the system
fairer for everybody mr mayor and doing
it in a way
that protects those with the lowest
incomes thank you
thank you councillor weston councillor
ants do you have the right to reply
councillor amnesty
thank you mr mayor i'll just be brief um
councillor carter's reference to 124
families who will be affected by this
there's 124 families that are going to
have to find hundreds of pounds a year
to send the children to the schools
that they want and it was often reminded
to me uh previously again that
i knew the cost of everything in the
value of nothing well i play that back
to the labor group
um this evening and just say um that
this isn't a case of a level playing
field
it is leveling down and it's something
that could have been resolved this
evening
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
anstey
we're going to go to a vote and
i'm advised that the voting mechanism is
in place
will be shortly yes there it is
everybody so you can all vote
[Music]
has been lost everybody can everybody
see the results
nobody can see the results so that
motion has been lost
[Music]
okay motion 9b the second motion this
evening concerns the union learning fund
counselor slater please could you move
this motion
thank you mr mayor the union learning
fund was introduced in 1998 to support
trade unions
to widen access to learning for workers
whether they were in a union or not
for more than 20 years the union
learning fund has supported working
people
who access skills and training at work
that they did not achieve
through normal education routes last
year alone
200 000 learners got new skills through
the union learning fund
because this is a government it's a
government paid fund
and they assist many people to improve
their reading writing numeracy i.t
skills and many other subjects
of those 200 000 learners 62
got basic english 62 000 sorry got basic
english maths
and i t skills through the fund and
thousands got their first ever
qualifications
many gaining mvq level one and once
they've achieved these initial
qualifications
they carry on on their on their
education road
as the learning is done at a convenient
time and is delivered at a pace that is
inclusive
only unions through their network of
reps have reached the numbers of
learners
the department for education has failed
to reach
and has delivered relevant learning for
workers
in the middle of a pandemic in the
deepest recession in our lifetimes
it's clearly if this is not the time to
cut training to workers
the government promised us at the last
election less than a year ago
that it wanted to level up and now
states that it intends to draw
withdraw the fund as of march 2021
it's a clear that the message is there
with no leveling up for workers
who need this support to gain equality
of learning and improving life
opportunities
for these people that have been left
behind we need the union learning fund
government promise to reskill workers
and the ulf does this
unfortunately this promise has now been
reversed it is the decision to end the
units at the union learning fund that
needs to be reversed
not the promise to level up we need to
keep learners learning
and the ulf at the heart of the economic
recovery plan
from this pandemic employers value the
learning fund
employers like tesco tata steel several
major airports the nhs and many many
more
businesses written privately to the
secretary of state for education
asking for a reversal of the decision as
they believe it is a very short-sighted
one
if you look at the motion in front of
you today you will see that there have
been independent evaluations of the fund
you will note that the returns of the
fund
and the um they far outweigh the cost
to government currently we must call on
the government to res uh to reverse this
decision
and to put the ulf at the heart of
building back better from colvid
to make sure it brings equality of
learning for those that other
educational institutions have left
behind
workers with greater education have more
transferable skills
and will be employment ready as we
recover from the current situation
we call on this council to express its
public support
for the union money fund to speak to our
mps from every party to get the
government to understand the importance
of the ulf
and asked them to reverse this decision
the government the economy the taxpayer
and the learner
get much more back than actually the 12
million pound that the fund
costs us currently so please support the
motion
i move thank you thank you councillor
slater
i understand the leader of the council
council of western's going to second the
motion
thank you mr mayor i'll be very brief
firstly just to
confirm as i am sure they are with all
colleagues that my trade union
memberships are listed on my declaration
of interest
but having said that mr mayor this this
motion refers to a much broader issue
which is of the um massive
massive loss that the union would be in
terms of people of working age
upskilling themselves achieving the sort
of um basic
skills that the councilors later set out
it would be an
absolutely tragic loss and we've just
heard about something
that the conservative group considered
to be a fairly insignificant sum of
money
mr mayor in terms of national budgets
for what this delivers in terms of 200
000 learners
this would be a total tragedy and so i
second the motion thank you
mr mayor thank you councillor weston
many members wishing to speak to this
[Music]
look in the chat facility and i haven't
got the raised hand facility on my
screen
so if you do need to speak might be
better
if you're going to wave to me can i
speak
councillor evans you'd like to make a
comment uh thank you thank you mr mayor
and i won't allude to the coincidence
that this was brought in in 1998
and funding should go directly to
properly contracted training providers
further education colleges and i don't
believe it should be
channeled through unions the
government's brought in a new
lifetime skill guarantee to give adults
the chance to take free college courses
and which is recognized and valued by
employers
and that has been announced a lifetime
learning from next april
what we should be doing is asking the
government to bring that forward
there is 2.5 billion being committed and
i just do not believe this is the right
route
to be channeling these funds
thank you councillor evans we're going
gonna go to a vote
if nobody else is looking to speak
counselor taylor
like to comment thank you mr mayor very
briefly i just
i'm very pleased to support this motion
and i think the uh withdrawal
of the union learning fund reflects the
contempt
with which this tory government um hold
trade unions in sadly i think it
represents
uh to curtail this funding i think
represents a
very short-sighted and slash-and-burned
approach to
supporting working people to better
themselves
and make a valuable contribution to the
economy and society at large
through um work based learning that is
funded through trade unions and sadly
that content is also reflected
in the uh comments from the leader of
the opposition
i'm very proud to support this motion
and thank councillor slater for
bringing this to the chamber this
evening thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor taylor councillor
boats you'd like to comment
it's all right there mr mayor um
question's already been asked thank you
okay thank you
nobody else is looking to speak i have
the right to reply mr mayor
you do miss council slater just bear
with me any other members wishing to
speak
councillor haddad
your mute again counselor dad
gosh excuse me sorry um thank you
um i object actually counselor taylor
to your comments about the conservative
party
having contempt for workers and for
education for our country
in fact on the country we have done
nothing more
than reduced the gap
in our leveling up agenda and
i think what it's about is about putting
in
structured learning for workers
where they have rights and where there
is good
solid education
from good providers and putting a
standard
in place where money should be spent on
them
as long as there is a good standard
and it's not just a free-for-all
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
haddad
um council slater you have the right to
reply
thank you mr mayor and i'm sorry i
didn't declare um an interest at the
beginning i am a uni
i am a union member and i don't know um
what council had was gone about and
she's talking about a free-for-all that
that just doesn't make any sense to me
because the money is monitored
you can see from the motion that
actually it's it's um there's checks and
balances in in all that
i don't agree with anything that
councillor evans said um he didn't
actually
he must have listened to a word that i
said because i told him that business
agrees with the union learn new funds
because it's quite clear
that the unions can reach more people
than any educational institution can
whether they are in a trade union or not
so i think you might need to reread the
motion have a
think about what i said and perhaps you
might want to support
people who need education
thank you council slater and we're going
to go to the vote
and the voting is there in front of you
can we see the result on screen yep and
that has been carried that motion is
carried thank you
motion 9c the third motion
is headed a fair grade for all and you
understand that there is an update
on this item from the leader of the
council council
you'll be deferring the item mr math
thank you thank you
councillor weston uh motion 9d the final
motion this evening concerns
accountability
and transparency transparency in
tackling the
climate emergency and is to be moved by
council of cognos
councillor coggins like to move the
motion thank you chair
you can't change what you can't measure
so this motion
so it's designed to help us tackle the
climate emergency in an accountable
and transparent manner it focuses on
changes that are doable
reasonable and cheap i'm glad to see
that the labour amendment plans to keep
much of the original
motion and we welcome in particular at
the announcement of a citizens assembly
which is something the green party have
been calling for for some time now
however we need to also look at what the
labor motion as a labor amendment
removes from the original motion
sadly the call for quarterly monitoring
of emissions has begun
we have only seven years of our carbon
budget left
and we need to make 13.4 percent
reductions in our carbon emissions
every year from now on with the time so
short and the stake so high it would
have really helped us if we could see
what was happening on a quarterly basis
so we would know what was working what
wasn't and we could adjust accordingly
there's also some interesting changes to
the language in the in the
labor amendment the word polluting is
taken out the description of the
admissions cuts we need to make as
massive
is gone and a quote from anthesis that
says the council must be more proactive
and give us higher priority give this
higher priority than before
has also gone now there's a certain
irony to taking those words out of
emotion about accountability and
transparency
if we are to beat this we really need to
acknowledge
the damage that we're doing and we need
to recognize the scale
of the crisis that we're facing but i do
realize that the administration is
starting to wake up to the climate
crisis
however they still support increased
airport use
the flawed prioritization of economic
growth over climate justice
building of the carrington relief road
across valuable wetlands
and hundreds of millions of pounds worth
of our trafford pension funds
being used to prop up shell bp and the
other fossil fuel giants
our generation has a unique and awesome
responsibility
what we do or don't do in the coming
months and few short years will truly
leave a lasting legacy
so we must stop thinking of the climate
crisis as a side issue
and put it at the heart of everything we
do and every decision we make
this motion is a step towards making
this change thank you
thank you councillor coggins councillor
jerome will second the motion councillor
jerome
thank you man i will second the motion
and i would also like to
speak to it also if that's okay um in in
2006 sir nicholas stern produced the
most highly regarded report on climate
change and economics today
the review states that climate change is
the greatest and widest range of
raging market market failure ever seen
but the main conclusion
is that the benefits of strong early
action on climate change
far outweigh the costs of not acting in
2006 he advised that governments spent
one percent of gdp on climate change
and in 2008 he upped this to two percent
however
subsequent labour lib dem and tory
governments
have squandered the chance to address
this that was over 10 years ago
we are now in the last chance saloon
this motion uh notes
that we are faced with some stark and
urgent choices
but we but we must start to reduce our
carbon emissions now
we simply ask that this is done in a
transparent way
and we have mechanisms for measuring and
charting progress
that counselors have the tools by which
to track
scrutinize and question our climate
change targets
we believe that we must bring residents
with us we welcome that communication
process is needed here
we can't succeed with more air and road
expansion
at the expense of cycle lanes by
supporting this motion
i believe we are sending out a message
to other councils on how to do this
right
so i urge you all to support this motion
thank you chair
thank you councillor jerome um
the leader of the council has given
notice of an amendment to the motion
is that moved please uh it is moved mr
mayor in doing so can
i just um make an alteration
to the amendment which i have agreed in
advance
with the green group i understand also
the council of butt will be
making an amendment to reflect a prime
ministerial announcement of last week
which we will also be supporting
but just to clarify on the
um on the change that that i
wish to notify of now um
it is at point one
um and it is where it says council
further supports the following actions
proposed by the executive
in the carbon neutral action plan if we
could just say council further supports
the following actions
and then move straight into adding
climate change onto the corporate risk
register um they are actions proposed in
the corporate risk register
uh sorry they are actions proposing the
carbon neutral action plan but we have
done some of it already
not least putting the corporate risk
register um
climate change onto the corporate risk
register so um
that is accepted and we will also be
accepting the
amendment um that councillor dylan will
make the slight alter
dillon book will make after um i
this has moved forward sorry i'm a
little all over the place i've never
done two
um alterations to an amendment before mr
mayor however
um turning to the to the substantive
here i think we've got
certainly a friendly amendment we've
also got an amendment that whilst it
doesn't necessarily include some of the
language that councillor cobbins
um may have favored in the original
version of the motion
is actually going some way further in
certain areas she referenced the
um citizens assembly it's also got
considerably further information around
some of the governance work
um being undertaken than the substantive
motion but i do have to say
that we have removed some stuff because
simply as a labor group we don't agree
with that so for instance and councillor
coggins neatly highlighted this for us
in her speech
the suggestion that the green you know
the green actions are
always the ones that best tackle
inequality i i
failed to see that the residents of
partington would agree with that
because they are very clear that the
relief road will allow them to access
jobs and opportunities
and that is a community that is isolated
that it is one of our um lower income
areas um in terms of indices and
multiple deprivation it scores highly
and we need to ensure that those
opportunities are available
to that community a further example was
the reference to
um the greater manchester pension fund
now we all support sensible divestment
but i fail to see how we support people
um you know and make the best decisions
for people's futures if it therefore
damages their pension and so that is why
i support that in a measured way
divestment yes immediate overnight
divestment
no um i think the other thing that i
would just say about that
um you know is that there were
a number of choices of words
in there that actually whilst i may not
disagree with all of them
did amount to slightly hyperbolic
rhetoric and there was just no no need
to be using words like massive which was
one that councillor coggins
used i'm not disagreeing that that is
the case but it's not
um what is important in this motion and
in this amendment is the action that we
take and we can tell the story however
we wish but i feel that we've got here
a more professional a more detailed and
actually
um and more restrictive
in terms of a more concrete rather set
of recommendations here that in some
ways go considerably further than a
slightly woollier original
motion so it's for those reasons that we
put forward the
um amendment noting the change um and
i've agreed with council copies in
advance and cognizant of the change then
i'm also
happy for the labour good support from
councillor but which i think will follow
shortly thank you mr matt sorry that was
a little messy
sorry everybody i'm on mute there and we
need a seconder for that one
thank you mr second amendment uh
obviously i've cut down significantly
what i was going to say
and that was about giving the time uh i
think that the most
the amendment before was makes it much
more practical
manageable and transparent and more
easily be able to implement
uh the things that we need to do within
the report the task is huge absolutely
no doubt on that
and implementing any of the workers
council the western's highlight it was
about to fit in
within air structures at the moment as
it was previously proposed
it would have actually been that much
more difficult and manageable and it
would have been all over the place
the amendment what makes this much more
realistically measurable in that respect
and
within the important structures the
visual emotion wasn't necessarily
bureaucratic
and in some parts unmanageable the
amendment
will also make sure it gives credit to
the work that's going on and contained
with both the anthesis support that
we've taken on
and report that is going to executive
next week which members haven't seen
that i do wish to look at that it's
having clearly
and detailed an exhaustive report which
actually really gives
the task ahead of us that i'm
particularly pleased at the work we're
doing
with partners community groups and
businesses and how we're getting them on
board
and it's a lot of detail of actually how
we can actually take that forward
and essentially and obviously one of the
groups will actually have elected
members on it as well
across the different parties and that's
clearly this force so we can actually
get involved across a piece in that one
i'm also
pleased that as the meeting can be seen
then the asks
sorry i'm just left in place there seems
in the report that many of the asks
are in that reporter's context and
reporting last week
in light of that i'm somewhat surprised
that the original motion
was not withdrawn i wasn't quite sure
that had the report uh
been published last week i'm quite sure
that some people in the chamber would
have actually been trying to claim
credit
for that in that executive report going
forward so i think clearly
administration
in that sense of it and i think clearly
what i said at last executive
particularly and i'll finish in a second
mr burke in the time obviously there's a
lot of things that run alongside this
and no detail that
at the last executive including because
i mentioned that all the active travel
the clean air plan and all those sorts
of things
now whilst they're not deliberately
related to the carbon emissions in that
century
they have to be an integral part of that
work um something that
we can join with the communities
actually getting them all to take it
forward we also don't see carbon
monoxide training atmosphere
for councillors and uh for our staff we
also i'd also like to see it looked at
in maine
actually how we can engage with local
communities so we can our residents can
actually learn how to do
what we can actually to support the
structure i know many many of them
actually want to do this
so with that mr mayor i will leave it at
that in that sense given the time so
other people can speak in that
thank you thank you councillor anste
i'm advised councillor but as a slight
alteration to the amendment councillor
but
thank you mr mayor uh as the leader
alluded to uh
i'd like to propose this uh on point
four
of the amendment as an identity
uh which is which currently states that
to work with other agencies and
authorities on reducing traffic's
indirect emissions as well as direct
emissions
and put in an end addition to that
in contributing to the prime minister's
ambitious target of cutting
emissions by 68 by 2030
based on 1990 levels
thank you thank you councillor but i
think uh
that that slight alteration is accepted
by council of western
it is mr mayor yep that's fine okay
um are we happy to support that motion
man well that's
our amendment right just bear with me
without discussion may ask that the
meeting consents to the proposed
alteration
[Music]
yes
counselor but we need to know your
amendment
would you just bear with me everybody
just bear with me to repeat it
okay i'm advised that council of western
has agreed an alteration with councillor
coggins
and we need that detail i will happily
detail that for you now mr mayor so at
point
one of the things that the council
um welcomes and the
actions and commitments taking forward
at the third sentence of that fairly
meaty paragraph
i think it's the third sentence it says
council further supports
the following actions proposed by the
executive
in the carbon neutral action plan adding
climate change onto the corporate risk
register
including carbon reduction waiting in
all procurement etc etc
we wish to remove the words proposed by
the executive in the carbon neutral
action plan
so it would now just read council
further supports the following
actions adding climate change onto the
corporate risk register
including carbon reduction waiting etc
etc
okay um without discussion may ask that
the meeting consents to the proposed
alteration hi
[Music]
everybody the amendment now with the
proposed alteration has been moved and
seconded
do any members wish to speak to the
amendment
counselor broke indicate that you'd like
to speak counselor brophy
just clarify how long i've got first mr
yeah two minutes please counselor brophy
thank you
thank you mr so i'm speaking
on the amendment and the motion together
okay because i'm assuming the amendment
will be passed so in 2018 i was proud
that trafford council were one of the
first local authorities
to declare a climate change emergency
with a joint green
and liberal democrat motion with all
party support from trafford
so the challenges we face in tackling
global warming
are massive even greater than covert 19
and of course it's far more difficult to
have policies that actually reduce
carbon
than just the process of declaring
emergency
that's where the work on this begins
with the antithesis report that's going
to traffic council success
as the notion states we only have seven
years of time left
and the window for action in trafford
across the world is getting smaller
so i welcome on behalf of the liberal
democrat group that chapel council are
bringing
forward a carbon neutral action plan
we welcome that we will be considering
the carbon reduction implications of all
our decision making including our
procurements
i welcome that trafford will be working
with other agencies on reducing
both the indirect emissions that will be
challenging as well as the direct
emissions that will be
a very very important piece of work in
reducing all of our emissions in
trafford
and finally on behalf of everybody
in traffic council the challenges of
climate change are
above party politics so let's all
support
this motion and let's make sure we
support the
required work that council will have to
do to make sure the actions to reduce
carbon are successful
doing all we can to make sure we sustain
our global future
and locally here in trafford we do
everything possible
to reduce carbon to tackle climate
change
thank you councillor brought free and
thanks for your patience um council
accordingly you have two minutes
thanks chair um yeah i really um
i'm pleased that this amendment's been
made um
i'm delighted um i think it's important
that
actually with all the sort of
sparringness going on about who whose
idea first and what have you
this is a really important issue and we
mustn't lose that
i so i really welcome the the whole
amendment and there's a lot of good
stuff in there
from all parties that can support that
in terms of um
i also welcome the the increased status
that
uh climate change has been given with
the
responsibility being taken on by the
leader and
i think that's important too because we
knew need to move with this
um the climate emergency
it attracts polarized views and we we've
struggled with that
and i think sometimes it's like a
pendulum we have to take
one side or the other and often it's not
the right side
um so i particularly welcome citizens
assemblies and
residence panels because i think that
has to be a way where people
look at this sensibly and look at the
crisis that's facing us
over this so i think that's really
important
um and i just welcome the whole thing
in all honesty i'm delighted it's not
being chucked out i'm delighted that we
uh unlike a council united state i i i'm
delighted that the
original motion wasn't withdrawn because
i think we've ended up with a really
good motion
and i'm really pleased with it thank you
mr mayor
thank you council accordingly councillor
welton you have two minutes thank you
thank you um well really council
accordingly has taken the words out of
my mouth
um so often he's very worth listening to
and on this case uh
this this is no exception absolutely
welcome
the uh the citizens assembly idea i mean
it's time that we had an
honest discussion with with our
communities about these things
and there are so many changes happening
at the moment um
good meaningful changes um to active
travel the clean air consultation
these kind of things will will be
brought into focus they'll
be given clarity um if we are honest
and about what we need to do
the things that we need to do in our
borough to meet our carbon targets 13.4
percent reductions a year is massive you
don't need to certain the motion
necessarily
but it is massive it's going to have an
implication on everybody's lives
the way that we live and if we don't get
communicate that across and we start
making changes that affect people's
lives without winning that argument
first then we will get that push back
and life will be very very difficult
thank you thank you councillor welton um
councillor coggins you have the right to
reply
thank you chair and and thank you for
the um old party support we have tonight
which we've had before in previous
climate motions and it really is
appreciated we do need to to work
together on this
um i do um accept the amendments we've
had and i wanted to bring up um a few of
the comments that we've heard
briefly and as cancer wesley knows we
have never called for immediate
overnight
divestment we've called for um the
greater manchester pension to do what
many other pension funds uh
including local authority pension funds
in this country and many others across
the world have done and take
sensible steps uh to divest uh
as quickly as possible and greater
manchester venture fund is is not doing
that
and on the matter of inequality i mean i
really think this is a really
fundamental point you know the effects
of the climate crisis
are being and will continue to be felt
most acutely by
the poorest communities in the global
south and by low income communities
in the industrialized north there is no
two ways about it that is the fact
climate justice is social justice
and we these people are bearing the the
burden of the effects of our
you know of our of our lifestyles and
this is why we need to just transition
we need to think about the poorest
people and the faster we can act
the more chance we have of protecting
their livelihoods and indeed
their lives um
i was um i do think the language we use
matters as well and the fact is
we're now told we have seven years of
emissions left in trafford
the information about the climate
emergency the rational arguments have
been known for
30 years and we haven't acted
so actually the way we talk about this
does matter and we've got to use frankly
every tool we have at our disposal to
get action on this and language is one
of those
and i was slightly bewildered by
councils or adsense comments and there's
no reason to withdraw this
following the publication of the exact
paper only 0.4 in my original motion was
covered in the exact paper everything
else is not covered in there
and so all the other i think eight
points that i had brought forward were
not covered in the exact paper
and and again in terms of any of the
requests being unmanageable none of that
was brought up this has been consulted
on for a few months with various uh
senior officers and the people who would
have to be doing this
and no one mentioned any of it being
unmanageable or woolly
and again how can three monthly
reporting be more woolly than
six monthly reporting um but i i will
leave it at that as i said that the main
point is that we have again all party
um agreement on this and um and i really
appreciate that and i really hope that
this will help us to keep us on track as
we go forward
thank you thank you councillor coggins i
will now put the amendment with the
proposed alteration to the vote
can we see the results on the screen i'm
not seeing it on my screen
should i should i be receiving
well i'm advised it as it has been
carried everybody so um
there it goes there we go
so the amendment is carried since we
have already had a substantial
discussion
i propose without any further debate to
move to the vote on the substantive
motion
if you'd like to vote in the usual way
[Music]
please
okay that motion has been carried
92
okay that is the end of the meeting um
please can i thank you for your
attendance
with christmas fast approaching may i
take this opportunity to convey
seasonal greetings to you all and hope
that you make the most
of these circumstances thank you
and good night thank you mr mayor good
night
[Music]